Rescuers
[Music]
why am I here Roman I need you we're
gonna destroy their whole nuclear
program
you know the risk trust me
please be safe with you okay
oh my God
pencils just came through the cia's
target's an Iranian nuclear facilities
our coverage boy we're leaving 15
minutes
distraction point it's an old CIA base
in Canada have problems
just want to go home and I'll be with
you
the distance is not the main issue
that's what's in between
any of them catch my guy will sell them
to the highest bidder there will be no
sanctity for you
raise your hands
do it before they get Trigger Happy
times
please
[Music]
tell me it was truly going on we cut
outs in an even bigger game this is my
life in your hands
let's go
no one is coming to rescue us
sorry
for everything
[Music]
foreign